a lot of the work is quite repetitive
the pleats took about two months to do
probably did those eyes 10 times
even the texture of the skin
their graceful dancing which i wanted to
portray
that's the whole goal is to make them
feel like they're gonna swim away
i'm stephen kessler also known as tusk
i'm a large-scale wildlife sculptor
i found sculpture a little later in life
in my late 30s
moving from one career to the other
especially into the art world that's
totally scary and foolish thing to do
i don't think i had an option after i
started sculpting i think my life was
going to be it no matter what i did
sculpture as a whole has inspired me
i mean it's a 24-hour thing for me sleep
just gets in the way almost
when i'm out doing day to day
things not being here it's always
running through my head
i don't know if i'd personally call
myself a daydreamer but i could probably
be labeled one
there is definitely a calming
with clay
i usually work 12 hours
for three days straight
being able to realize
what i want in it quickly
it just seems like it works together
with how i process
i've been involved with making three
life-sized giraffes
40-foot whale shark
four manta rays
and we're working on this 30-foot iguana
behind me
the humpback whales took roughly nine
months
the inspiration to do these pieces for
the aquarium was
because utah is a landlocked state
there's a limited number of people that
you see these in real life anyways
to be able to be in the same room feel
the size of it
hopefully there's an energy to it and
hopefully inspire conservation packs
because of it if someone says oh i can't
sculpt i said if you tried buy it you
know you never know what's going to
happen
open the box of clay see what's in it
you know there might be a humpback whale
in the future
you